how do you think then with this
investigation in mind the polls actually
affected the way the campaign was
conducted from your point of view yeah I
think it's a lot more serious than just
the polling industry getting its
predictions wrong it affected campaign
judgments we made I think it affected
the media's coverage of the campaign and
possibly even affect the result a bit
too it meant that those final weeks of
the campaign were all dominated by Tory
stories about the risk of a Labour SMP
coalition that's what the media assumed
would be the result that somehow there
be a Labour government propped up by the
SNP and we couldn't get our stories
going about the risk of a second term
Tory government or the risk of a Tory
majority if we'd known if the public had
known that we're heading for a Tory
majority would be much easier to get a
debate about the risk of a Tory
government and I think we might well
have ended up at an apartment yeah it's
I mean it's interesting what you say
from from my point of view in the media
do you think therefore that remember
that that poster with Alex Salmond with
EDD Miliband in his top pocket there
looking down at him after Alex Salmond
was was joking when he said he'd be
writing Labour's first budget you think
that was a bull's-eye I think the Tories
were looking for ways to toxify the
Labour Party and we had all kinds of
problems I'm not making excuses saying
pollsters loss as the election we had
problems on the economy had problems I'm
leadership but I think that SMP story
acted as a catalyst to open up other
weaknesses we had and that relentless
focus day in day out it led the news the
SMP are they going to be in the
coalition are they going to be propping
up a Labour government what are the risk
of that and I think that must have had
an impact on voters wherever it sorted
sub to suppress our vote galvanized
Tories where it changed minds I don't
know but I certainly think that if the
polls have been accurate when it's in a
different campaign we're just seem
different campaign coverage and we might
just see a slightly different result
yeah i mean just one more on that
because see it again from from my side
of it talking to senior Labour Party
figures you're right hands up you know
the polls did lead to the questioning so
I would ask are you going to do a deal
with the SNP the answer
back no formal deal I'd ask the second
question saying well maybe a supply and
confidence deal then in other words
support their budget now we won't do
that either I say well maybe a vote by
vote deal and there we are most of the
interview taken up with the issue of
coalition I remember it very well and it
meant that the campaign was dominated by
this giant process story of what might
or might not happen after voters have
delivered their judgment now I think
there's lessons for the media for his
lessons obviously for pollsters there's
lessons for political parties about how
we use poles in campaigns because I
think in the end you want to have the
public given the chance to make a real
judgment about the relative merits of
political parties what the program
they're offering is rather than some
guessing game about what might happen
after people are voted that's what we
ended up with too much in the campaign
but I mean you know from your own point
of view you must have had your own
polling was it telling you the same
thing your internal polling yeah pretty
much there's some reports saying that we
knew we were going to lose that I don't
recognize those reports you know there
was a poll late on saying that we were
doing a little bit worse in some of the
marginals than we had expected but yeah
the fo the focus of our campaign what we
thought is a very tight campaign we
thought was a real chance of being a
hung parliament and in the mix to form
the next government and I think made us
all of a bit risk-averse probably Tories
to it affected the campaign in all kinds
of ways so today we're seeing a polling
industry coming out and saying we now
fixed it well they've got a big vested
interest in saying that they can be
trusted again I'm a little bit
suspicious of this yeah they're saying
well the problem the polls we didn't
reach enough Tory voters or we can all
tell you that I can tell you the problem
labor camp age we didn't reach enough
and labour voters you know it's I think
we need to have a bit of a ball
reflection on all this fair point but
you know people are going to say okay
and you did say you're not you're not
blaming the polls but you fundamentally
fail to deal with the key question that
Lynton Crosby on the conservative side
got them to to bang on about endlessly
which was the economy the long-term
economic plan and remember the moment
you i'm sure you remember it as well as
I do when Mr Cameron produced the Liam
burn note from 2010 outer is out of his
top pocket passing on to the then chief
secretary of the Treasury this is a bit
wonkish I know but it said there is no
money left it was a joke but that hit
home didn't it it did but I think we did
quite a lot in the campaign to actually
mitigate our weaknesses on the economy
and on leadership of the ed had a very
good campaign personally I think we
produced a fully funded fully costed
program we weren't going to be boring
any extra money I think people you
recognize that we'd actually had a good
campaign of that I think was the SNP
stuff this process story which was
actually untrue that we're going to go
into a deal with the SMP which was the
catalyst which opened up those problems
for us so I do think it affected the
campaign you can tell me now I mean you
must have had a chat with the SNP I mean
you know as you safe behind the scenes
you must have been thinking okay well if
it is hung they're going to take a lot
of labor seats maybe they could lend
them back and support us here we go in
the same interview no that wasn't the
case at all we in the circumstances
where we hadn't won a majority but had
been asked to form the government
because they're conservatives hadn't we
would have sought to govern on a
progressive program and if the SNP as
the party would said it was progressive
want to support us on individual bills
that would have been up to them that's
how the weird govern we were not going
to make a deal with the SMP one last
thought on that on the polls you know
given how things went wrong then we're
not that long after the general election
do you think they could be wrong now
about Jeremy Corbyn well the polls are
painting whatever reading you have a
pretty gloomy picture of labor's
prospects one year obviously i saw was
seven months after after general
election depending which way you read it
labourer 5 10 points behind i remember
there being huge debate in the labour
party and people tearing a hair out when
we weren't ten points ahead and people
are saying this a huge problem there is
a big big electoral problem for light
party now jeremy corbyn's simultaneously
kind of unassailable within a party but
viewed by a lot of people's unelectable
in the country and
i I'm not quite sure how you bridge that
gap and I think the Beckett report which
is coming out later de ballet part into
the reasons why we lost should be a
focus for debate and light party now
because we haven't had this debate about
why we lost and where we need to move
properly on from here too much the
debate is about who controls low party
and where does the Labour Party go in
this deselection or who's running the
NEC we should be talking about the
Tories and how we win that power and i
hope the baccarat bought gives us that
focus to begin doing that today but i
mean as you said there you had a bit of
a leadership issue with aid Miliband I
mean that's writ large isn't it with
jeremy corbyn well one of the
achievements of EDS leadership I think
was to remain the United Party for his
last Parliament and also right until the
end competitive with the Tories I don't
feel that light body is competitive with
the Tories at the moment I think Tory's
feel they more or less get away with
anything and that they're heading for a
third term I think that's nightly bad
for labour party I think it's very bad
for the country if the Tories think they
can get away of anything because the
opposition's just not going to be there
an exhalation Tom Baldwin must ended
their great talking to you thank you
very much indeed for your thoughts an
analysis so Tom Baldwin